intense smoke has filled New York City
and surrounding areas Long Island Jersey
all as a result of Canadian wildfires I
don't know how many of you regularly
check the air quality index but I've
been checking it quite a bit and to be
perfectly Frank I've basically been
staying indoors and limiting my time
Outdoors this is really bad and it's
been wild to see people dealing with you
know from during covid it was all about
Outdoors is where it's safe inside is
where you've got to wear the mask and be
worried about contagion we now have a
situation that has flipped this on its
head outside is where it's dangerous the
breathing is bad outside is maybe where
you want to wear the mask stay inside
for safety uh reportedly this is going
to dissipate but then maybe come back
again let me know in the comments have
you been
behaving in a different way as a result
of the smoke